albert breer here in the flesh they make
you return it then that's fine yes they
kept the receipt yeah okay
so it's here's till wednesday and then
it's going so this is the last hour yeah
and i think it goes to the nfl
experience from here gotcha
that's the real deal that's it that's
amazing i think there's two or three
maybe but oh that could be like a fight
club thing that they don't talk about
how many that there are but we have this
one here right i don't know if this is
the one going to be handed to the winner
of the game
uh they might make a new one for that i
don't know yeah i can't remember how
they i think i remember hearing at one
point how they do that and i just i
don't know the details are like one goes
to the maybe the owner keeps one and
then the team itself gets one yeah
something like that there's one that's
handed out and um and uh i can't wait to
see who it is this is this is a fun one
nobody saw this one coming i don't think
no i mean i just think the the story of
the contrasting styles you know like in
the way that they were built the bengals
are so old school small scouting staff
you know and then the young coaching
staff that stuck together through three
years and obviously a young quarterback
and a team that like legitimately looks
like this could be the front end of
something for them because there's so
many young players on the other side
you've got the forward thinking big
market rams right who are all in
um the fascinating match up you know and
i
i honestly like i i look at the
quarterbacks and i know that's always
where we go of course but
matthew stafford's chance to alter his
legacy here and to change the narrative
on him and how we're going to look at
those 13 years in detroit differently if
he wins this game
and then joe burrow
and i it's going to sound like sacrilege
but i think the closest thing
stylistically to tom brady we've seen
since brady was a young what have i been
saying to you guys here i'm not crazy
but that's the rich yes that that and
and if and if borough wins it
right yeah where where
he wins it in year two
after you know um a year one that for
brady obviously brady got to start
because another was injured and
and um burrow got his start because he
he was it was preordained as a first
overall pick but he's cut down due to
injury then in year two if he wins it
including a a playoff game against the
raiders where there was uh an
inadvertent whistle and this one and we
were talking about an officiating
decision right
and and then but the ultimate thing is
for me
for the rest of our days yeah our
children's days and you know our
grandchildren's days that we get to see
any kid that comes out of college and
wins so quickly will be
can he catch brady yep that is going to
be the conversation and i i think
this is what burrow has brought to the
fore and we've always we've already had
that like discussion on the homes you
know what i mean yeah that's what's
going on here for the super bowl it's
just like if he beats brady he's one
step closer
homes had won last year then that would
have been two and four years which
matches brady he had two through four
years also i think it goes beyond that
with burro though i don't think it's
just the winning early i i can remember
covering brady as a young player
and it's stylistically there are
similarities the accuracy the pocket
movement
i just think it's the mindset and you
know like one of the things that people
would always tell you about brady it's
not that he gets better in the bet in
the biggest moments it's that when
everything is
he's the same just total flat line
and i see the exact same thing with
burrow it's like when all hells break
when all hell's breaking loose around
him it's just he is he's like almost the
bellwether for the entire team and it
spills over to the way they play defense
and no one ever feels like they're out
of a game down 21-3 he gets sacked nine
times you know in tennessee
it's just it's nothing shakes him and
that's what to me like that's what's
similar with brady and then i mean the
21 bengals versus the 01 patriots the
other thing is you just kind of keep
winning like it's almost like in certain
games it's not a great explanation for
how it happened right but it keeps
happening and it's just sort of like
that bengals team sort of has that feel
that the one patriots had and look who
they're playing in the super bowl the
rams yeah
it's kind of crazy you know it's kind of
crazy it's interesting too um you know
the the brady that that borough's been
associated with the most so far is joe
brady because that was the you know the
guy at lsu
who was you know helping him become the
joe burrow we see today at lsu yep you
know um with coach oh being the coach at
lsu yep who gave him a shot at
lsu we're going to go there right
i mean
do you have the sound brockman of um do
we have a sound somewhere of joe burrow
saying that
they said
you know i heard that yeah
we're gonna go down the list i mean sam
hubbard plays for the bengals von bell
place for the bengals there are a lot of
buckeyes they're gonna be out there on
sunday very good i mean jordan fuller
captain of the rams not gonna play on
sunday but also another buckeye on the
other team captains on both sides of my
house i saw the other day we had this
conversation we were on when we talked
about harbaugh and you retweeted i'm not
in charge of editing i don't tell mike i
don't taste sean mitchell who's
fantastic at cutting up this show 50
million different ways on on literally
five minutes time he's amazing and
you're like but this guy edited it out
on the floor
you know that we didn't talk about how
many gold pants joe has all right three
sets three sets of gold pans uh now
moving on this is not making air um so
um
let's let's talk about um
kyler murray yep
because any and and i i started the show
by saying boro has already
already done what you want a number one
pick to do yeah get you to the super
bowl change the culture change it all
the way around
and we're still waiting for murray to
win his first playoff game and it's not
as if he hasn't been surrounded right
okay in the same way that we see chase
and higgins and boyd and mixon we have
deandre and aj aj formerly of the
bengals right and so on and so forth
what is up
with kyler two things i think the one is
like that i think players are gonna be
less afraid to push their way out if and
i'm not saying kyler is but i think that
that's one thing that's like very clear
now and we've seen that and there are
different ways to do it like the two
guys in the rams jaylen ramsey and
matthew stafford went about it very
different ways they both got out right
and so like i think that that exists
like the guys view that as a viable
option even if you're the quarterback
because it used to be sacrilege for a
quarterback to do that
um the second thing is the way the
season ended i think left a mark there
and i can tell you like things were very
uncomfortable in that building that week
the next day they had the sort of
personnel meeting that every team has at
the end of the year leading pardon me
leading up to the playoff game after the
playoff game the days after the playoff
game so the day after the season ended
they had a personnel meeting where you
know all the coaches the every team does
coaches scouts come in
and they all talk about like okay like
here's what we're gonna do here and here
and here to set up the off season
that was abruptly canceled for a couple
days after that no one got word on what
was going to happen with cliff it was
just a lot of people were left like
hanging in the balance kyler is very
close with cliff of course
and you sort of wonder if kyler sees
this as oh my god are we going into a
situation
where the organization could be
destabilized after this year by firing
the coach yeah and because because
because of the way the season ended
because things were so uncomfortable
there i know for some people in that
building i don't know about kyler
specifically but there were some people
that walked away from that
thinking like what's the owner going to
do next you know and again like it may
be that cliff kingsbury who i think has
done a good job there on balance for the
first three years took over one of the
worst rosters in football they're in the
playoffs three years later he did a good
job getting them there
i just feel like there was a little
uneasiness throughout that organization
in the days after the season i think
that left a mark with some people and so
you do wonder kyle's at this point in
his career now
he's played three years he's eligible
for a new contract and you go down the
list of guys who got paid after three
years most of the big ones did josh
allen did um deshawn watson did patrick
mahomes did carson wednesday jared goff
did
are they going to pay him this off
season and you saw like the browns chose
not to do that with baker after last
year right
how awkward was it this year
pretty awkward right it seems like it i
mean
it certainly seems like it so
all right so
you're saying that the way that things
were maybe
up in the air in regards to kingsbury
and kyler's a kingsbury guy yeah and so
well he's thinking like what if they're
going to fire the coach i want to get
paid it's just so it's like
i think it like and this is again this
is me speculating putting pieces
together but
like i i like i just think that there
was enough there where like there was
enough going on with it being eligible
for a contract the fact that his you
know the coach who brought him in i
don't know if they take kyle or murray
first overall cliff kingsbury's not the
coach i think you'd agree with that like
that probably that might not happen
because they've just taken josh rose in
the year before
i think it's like all these things
play into it kyler can be a little up
and down too like he can be a little
moody too so
like i i certainly think that there's
some stuff that they're at the very
least there's gonna be some stuff
they're gonna have to work out kyler and
don't forget like
i'm not saying it's gonna happen but
kyler also has an escape hatch a lot of
other people don't have well not not
until you know
unless he wants to play in japan you
know what i mean like i guess right like
right now this looks horrible what's
going on but they're already you know uh
the last time the owners called for and
you remember standing on a street corner
yeah all those years during the nfl
lockout i was in studio you're on a
street corner in washington dc yeah
we're talking to each other all the time
when when uh owners
call up and say we want a federal
mediator yeah that's
bad that's bad
you're hitting the new killer button
yeah so that's where things are right
there
so i i just why why in all the
speculation that we're talking about
does kyler make it public
like what's the point of that what's the
point that's the way like i i like
i i think that's the way that guys like
i don't really relate with that as much
but i think that's the way the
generation does it like you know it's
like let everyone know i'm pissed
don't blame me i mean like what is that
it's like ghosting a girl right like
it's like i'm gonna go think about this
so i'm just not gonna talk to her for a
few days i guess i mean i i don't think
it's anything
by the way great for you man i was on
the business end of that ghosting many
times
interesting
but i do think like
the amount of effort it takes to do
something like that
there's something to do honestly like go
ahead and do it and well you know what
it's going to look like go ahead and do
it and you know our our friend ian
rappaport spoke to his agent who's like
no comment right so what's the cause
it's an easy chance i mean like remember
we're going to remember like what is it
yeah i mean like and what ian said like
i don't know if he pointed this part out
but that agent who represents tyler
also represents cliff
so
i mean he'd have both ends of it but you
got to know that the no comment just
keeps this well that that's
exactly like that's that's what i'm
saying so we we fill the vacuum in a
conversation on during super bowl week i
mean you know what's going on right yeah
and that that that that people are going
to talk about it and what's the point of
that like who are you putting the
pressure on like what we he he's let it
be known he's unhappy with us we have to
give him a contract that starts with a
four right now
when you know honestly
this thing has not finished up past
thanksgiving very well
every year that this combination has
been working together and this team well
no showed in the building of the super
bowl i was there that night it wasn't
even close that thing tyler didn't play
well either it was well i mean there was
one play where he was
remarkable in escaping yeah uh the the
marauding defensive line at him and he
made some throw on the run that almost
hit i forget which receiver i think it
was christian kirk streaming down the
field yeah almost hit him on the run and
if he'd hit him right there that was a
touchdown and things might have been
different maybe
but other than that so i mean what if
your management what do you what are you
doing i mean that's the hardest to
restore his instagram account in our
relationship well let's say let's say
that let's say that uh that they
like are thinking about this being
cliffs last year and they don't extend
the cliff because cliff you know is
going into the fourth year of his
contract too they haven't renewed him
either and you remember there was the
brief flirtation with the oklahoma job
right like if they're not extending
cliff
and they're going into the
season thinking to themselves we may not
have we may not like have cliff
kingsbury pass this year
it's like tough to pay kyler then isn't
it because if you pay kyler now
then whoever the next coach coming in
like whoever that is is going to be
saddled with kyler's contract i don't
think maybe saddled that saddle is the
wrong word but he's certainly it settles
if he's not that good he's a unique type
of quarterback who i don't think fits
for everybody you know what i'm saying
like so like i think
if you like
part of it is like like if there are
eight or nine openings again next year
and you're the cardinals and you want to
attract the very best coach
like the best situation is yes to give
him kyle murray but give him kyle or
murray with some options but give him
kyle murray and say we haven't paid him
yet so we got to work through that if
you really like them great if not like
maybe we go with go into the fifth year
option with them rather than
like every coach who comes in has to be
married not dating because if you pay
him that much married to kylo murray and
that i i think that that's a factor too
because
like um when kyler came into the league
it was very specific like this guy's
going first overall because he's cliff
kingsbury's type of quarterback
are you guaranteed that the next guy who
you might like out there is going to
feel the same way about him last one for
you albert before i send you onto this
good wednesday um i'm going to do what's
more likely chris i'm sorry to steal
your thunder here
but i'm going to give a third option
what's more likely roger's back with
green bay brady back with tampa or
neither
roger's back with green bay
i think if brady comes back it's with
another team
i think there was some level of and i i
think brady loves the guys he worked
with okay like loves jason light loves
bruce arians loves byron leftwich i do
think that there were little things that
frustrated him there
and having come from his titan operation
as he came from for 20 years that's
perfect situationally that knows how to
handle everything that is so bit
buttoned down and business-like
i mean
i i think that there were things as far
as the way
i mean like from in-game things to like
the antonio brown the handling of the
antonio brown situation
that i think over time started to get to
him a little bit and so i don't think
he's coming back as a tampa bay
buccaneer now if there's a contender out
there that he aligns with that has a
quarterback injury like then maybe like
you could see it where that team comes
in and says calls tampa and says could
we work something out where tom could
come here and maybe tampa would would
accommodate that i think the big thing
to keep in mind here
i think brady has been this is my
perception of it but i think brady's
been fearful of what this is going to be
like because he's such a competitive
person and he's had that competitive
outlet for so long
that
like he doesn't know how he's gonna feel
in three months he doesn't know how he's
gonna feel in six months so i think
that's why he leaves that door open with
jim gray
and you know i don't like i don't think
he goes back to tampa
because i think that team's going to
look markedly different too i think
that's another piece of the puzzle
because now they're off now now that
brady's not there anymore i think that
they're going to retool some things
i mean i do think that frustration was
there but if there's a bona fide
contender
that like say san francisco is five and
oh and say trey lance gets hurt and i'm
not wishing injury on anybody obviously
but just hypothetically i already got it
yeah
yeah would that be a nice cabinet
all right let's just let's just go the
the one step further is it possible
since as you know
you know
although i'm i'm i'm hearing his agent
is like getting out of the business now
right selling or something like donyi
because he's like if brady's gone like
he always said it when brady leaves i'm
leaving and things like that so i'm just
wondering though is it possible that
this was part of a plan
to say i'm i'm going to retire like bro
like brett favre
and then leave the door open
to let everyone know i'm still available
potentially for the right thing
because he didn't want to stick with
tampa anymore because he saw the way
things were going is it possible
because you know
one thing that doesn't compute on all of
this is somebody who's so meticulous and
has been so terrific and so meticulous
that the whole
retirement thing has just been a head
scratcher from the way that it was
either leaked and out there and then
not immediately well if it's out there
then here comes the instagram and twit
twitter right and then having your shot
on your own podcast which would have
been the most downloaded podcast period
all week yeah
passing that up then tweeting and
instagraming out you're retirement and
then six days later it seems like giving
the never seen ever is what you're
saying unless it's
particularly so on purpose well i mean i
know this is crazy but i'm just throwing
it around and look at tampa's free agent
list right it's it's vast it's unbelie i
mean it's remarkable he kept it together
for one year i mean leonard fournette
carlton davis chris godwin ryan jensen
alex kappa jason pierre paul and dominic
and sue
it is an enormous list they've only got
20 million dollars to spend
like i just like i don't think that like
i don't know if brady planned this but
if there's a way to convince tampa to
move on from you it would be after they
get through all of that right like so
yeah yeah cause five or six months from
now maybe brady transmitted if they
decide like okay like we have to tear
this thing down a little bit we'll take
our medicine from a cap standpoint this
year
and now they've got a lesser team in six
months do they want brady bad and one
thing you know for sure what brady's
gonna do between now and then is not uh
you know let himself go
you know what i mean that's the most
interesting part of it though like i
mean you might have like one and a half
cheating i don't know man like i mean
i'm in my 40s now i'm i'm in my 40s now
my knees hurt when i walk up the stairs
so i can't imagine what it takes like a
45 year old guy to be ready to play
professional football that's correct
because he's still going to be out there
with the with the resistance bands in
april take that for granted we so take
that for granted yeah it's alex guerrero
so i'm sure he'll be ready albert breer
thanks for the time sir awesome always
grateful javian next week if you're up
for calling in about what we're seeing
on sunday you got we'll be in india in
what two weeks yes we will and i'll see
you there as well check out this man's
work the mmqb and on sports illustrated
as well hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here